[Musik]
kinder kinder
hallo ich bin heute politik
vertretungslehrer herr diesen kötter
fernandes ab burnout wird eine pussy zu
meiner zeit sind lehrer einfach
alkoholiker geworden
aber egal thema heute der bundestag
einige von euch sind volljährig und
werden im september das erste mal was
diese eine wichtige sache die man erst
mit 18 darf bumsen nein tim julian nicht
um zum luca alexander ist mir doch
scheißegal nach selb am 24 september ist
bundestagswahl wählen wer land regieren
man es gibt verschiedene parteien für
die ihr euch entscheiden können
also wenn ihr cdu wählt bleibt angela
merkel kanzlerin wenn ihr spd wählt
bleibt angela merkel kanzlerin ganz
einfach grün wählen ist wie
alkoholfreies bier trinken fühlt sich
gesund an bringt aber wirklich gar
nichts
die fdp besteht aus einer einzigen
person christian lindner
wenn ihr den geld dann bleibt angela
merkel kanzlerin richtig sehr gut was
noch die linke waren nicht finde ich
ganz klein
diedorf kleine alte grenzen
was mit der alster fdm fdp kann ich
nicht muss eine dieser splitterparteien
sein die nur totale vollidioten wählen
sorry nichts für euch dabei moment als
schulsprecher und mitglied der jungen
union sage ich die cdu ist gerade für
junge menschen die vernünftige wahl weil
wir cd das ist das problem
die einzigen die sich politisch
beteiligen sind sagt gesichter wie malte
der wird auch ein politiker weil er für
einen richtigen job zu dorf ist hier
wenn ihr nicht mitmacht dann wird euch
das nach china regieren
also geht wählen so das war es für heute
aus aufgabe bis morgen werden
kanzlerkandidat der spd und verliert
dann hört sich schwerer an als es ist
[Musik]